en a las 4 y 45 de la madrugada cuando
sonaron las alarmas en la ciudad de iván
o francois al oeste del país y esta
misma escena se repitió en otras
ciudades que tenían en común tener
aeropuertos militares o fábricas de la
industria militar como es la ciudad de
luxe unipro donde fue bombardeado un
jardín infantil y residencias de civiles
como también se supuesta mañana en el
caso de iván o francos beasts donde nos
encontrábamos fue atacado el aeropuerto
militar aunque no se conocen de víctimas
como sí sucedió en dux donde habrían
muerto dos militares esto dicen que es
una estrategia de las fuerzas rusas para
evitar la reacción de los ucranianos
ante este asedio de la capital kiev que
se prevé para los próximos días ayer
dijo el alcalde de la ciudad que más de
la mitad de la población ya ha oído de
la capital y a esta hora estamos frente
a la carretera que une el este con el
oeste del país y cientos y cientos de
coches
hacia la frontera ya se conoce que más o
menos
2.5 millones de ucranianos han
abandonado el país en las últimas dos
semanas y muchas de estas personas van
en dirección también a buscar refugio en
países vecinos